[Musica]
pensate ad un momento triste
o di sconforto che avete vissuto da poco
quante volte
è stata d'aiuto una canzone un figlio un
disegno oppure una passeggiata nelle vie
della vostra città
pensate se non fosse per l'arte e per la
cultura in generale nei momenti
difficili
quanto sarebbe più complicato
andare avanti
penso infatti che la cultura possa
essere vista come
una forma di resilienza
come una forma di speranza e come
potremmo vivere senza la speranza
lo scorso anno abbiamo sperimentato
direttamente sulla nostra pelle
quanto la musica il cinema l'arte siano
stati un antidoto ai momenti bui
quanto la cultura in tutte le sue forme
ci abbia aiutati psicologicamente a
superare ea vivere quei momenti
difficili quanto essa
sia fondamentale per il benessere
psicofisico e sia un diritto umano
fondamentale
diversi studi riconoscono infatti come
la cultura migliori la qualità della
vita delle persone
l'arte per esempio viene impiegata nel
trattamento di diverse patologie
e
l'arte ed attività culturali sono
applicate in interventi di rigenerazione
urbana per ridurre fenomeni come la
criminalità e l'emarginazione
la cultura però
nonostante i comprovati effetti sul
nostro benessere
in troppi contesti ancora messa da parte
sacrificate considerata inspiegabilmente
direi come l'ultima ruota del carro e
qui vi è l'urgenza di dare vita ad una
nuova idea di welfare in cui la cultura
abbia veramente un ruolo cardine per il
nostro benessere e per la ripresa del
nostro paese delle nostre stesse vite
mantenere viva la cultura
preservare e valorizzare il patrimonio è
l'eredità che c'è stata consegnata
affidata non è una mera responsabilità
delle istituzioni ma e responsabilità di
ognuno di noi
se ci pensate è come la cura che
dedichiamo al nostro patrimonio
familiare
che viene tramandato dai nostri nonni ai
nostri genitori ed allora noi
un patrimonio che non è fatto solo di
case terreni preziosi è un patrimonio
fatto delle loro storie le loro
sacrifici dei loro sogni delle loro
speranze
la cultura può essere vista come un filo
che collega generazioni passate a quelle
presenti fino a quelle future
una mappa genetica che in sintesi
riassume la storia dell'umanità
ed è dunque nostro dovere far sì che
questo filo non venga spezzata che i
nostri figli i nostri nipoti e chi verrà
dopo di noi abbia la stessa fortuna e la
stessa opportunità che noi oggi abbiamo
di poter vivere e godere di questo
patrimonio
partendo dall'idea che la cultura sia la
vera cura tantissime associazioni in
realtà in italia nel mondo cercano di
dare voce ai bisogni e alle necessità
dei propri territori del proprio paese
dedicando il proprio tempo libero ad
attività culturali e di rigenerazione
valorizzazione del patrimonio
che penso
al volontariato culturale è inevitabile
per me pensare ad un immagine molto
evocativa che è quella degli angeli del
fango
giovani volontari provenienti da diverse
parti d'italia e del mondo che nel
1966 fecero risorgere una firenze
devastata dall'alluvione salvando così
opere d'arte e libri
anch'io nel mio piccolo
da circa fra tre anni dedico il mio
tempo libero al volontariato culturale
una delle esperienze più formative ed
arricchenti della mia vita
durante questo mio percorso ho
conosciuto tantissimi giovani
volenterosi di spendersi per la cultura
dedicare il proprio tempo libero a
qualcosa che spesso non dà risultati
immediati ma i cui frutti sono visibili
solo
stanza di tempo a volte anche di anni
è come il vento
descritto dalla poetessa christina
rossetti
si è visto il vento né io né te ma
quando le foglie tremano e il vento che
le attraversa e il volontariato
culturale richiede infatti tanta forza
di volontà quante volte si è rinunciato
ad un aperitivo con gli amici oppure
dormito ore in meno per poter
programmare delle attività che fossero
utili per la collettività per il
prossimo è un investimento di tempo di
risorse praticamente è come
svolgere un lavoro solamente chi non è
retribuito e questo per molti a volte è
totalmente incredibile ma vi posso
assicurare
che è molto di più dello stipendio che
si prenda a fine mese
perché chi fa volontariato in cambio
riceve gioia prova emozioni intense che
toccano profondamente la vita
si stabiliscono legame si crea una
famiglia legata a da passioni da un
progetto comune
penso a tutte le volte che con
l'associazione italiana giovani per
l'unesco
sono entrata nelle scuole che sono
incubatore di sogni speranze competenze
di tantissimi giovani
ed ho visto negli sguardi negli occhi
degli studenti e l'esperienza che stavo
condividendo con loro
era per loro d'ispirazione
penso infatti che sia importante
ispirare anche solo una persona
perché questa a sua volta sarà in grado
di ispirare altre persone creando un
effetto a catena e portando così ad un
vero cambiamento
e così
a fine giornata
so che i miei sforzi i miei sacrifici ne
sono valse la pena perché hanno avuto un
impatto su una persona su un territorio
su una collettività
e così tante altre persone come me
dedicano le proprie risorse personali in
termini di tempo competenze economie
accomunate dai medesimi valori e con
tanta voglia di spendersi di essere
cittadini attivi e responsabili per
lasciare un segno positivo nella società
tutti noi in fondo
sentiamo l'esigenza di
lasciare un segno
una traccia di noi su questo mondo
di realizzare qualcosa per gli altri
qualcosa che ci si muova dentro che ci
animi che ci faccia sentire la fiamma
avete idea
della sensazione che il corpo prova
quando si è felici
dico davvero
pensate
all'ultima volta in cui siete stati
felici
cosa cosa avete provato
cosa avete sentito
io
quando sono felice sento una scossa una
scarica di energia chi mi riempie di
brividi che mi fa sentire viva ed è lì
poi che sono in armonia con il tutto
in pace con tutto ciò che mi circonda
durante la mia esperienza di
volontariato culturale
ho provato spesso questa sensazione di
felicità
sono convinta infatti che la vera
essenza dell'essere vivo e quindi della
felicità si apportare qualcosa di buono
al mondo
sentirsi utili per gli altri
essere cittadini attivi e responsabili
l'artista marinella senatore
quella sua bellissima
installazione luminosa
lancia un messaggio
importante ovvero will rise by lifting
ad es
se leviamo
sollevando gli altri
questo è per me il volontariato
culturale
e se non l'avete ancora fatto
vi invito a trovare il vostro perché a
comprendere ciò che di smuove che vi fa
sentire vivi la fiamma che vi arde
dentro
il volontariato culturale è un ottimo
modo per iniziare a trovarla
grazie
[Applauso]